We are here again and the
beautiful youtube space,
New York in a studio filled with
lights and camera and now some action.
This particular action is going to be
talking about how computers can help
countries get along a little better.
Today we're going to talk about machine
translation and how it doesn't go so
well in the early days. Uh, the 80s,
well known for great fashion sense,
but guys with cheesy Russian accents
and fears of nuclear annihilation.
Maybe it's the coder and me,
but I have actually always wondered if
the Cold War would have been a bit, well,
you know, warmer if computers could
have helped us understand each other.
It turns out we tried just that.
Welcome to comp Tom.
The only show on the internets where
there's something colder than a Russian
winter.
Let me take you back in time to
lovely 1948 computers were a thing,
uh,
a new thing,
a big room sized thing that you've
had a feed with little tiny paper,
punched holes.
These binary loving behemoth were so
successful that folks actually started
wondering if there was any problem they
couldn't solve and what are those folks
that definitely couldn't
ignore their power.
Was Mr. Warren Weaver the
mighty power of the computer.
He kept bugging all of his
colleagues. Hey guys, you know what?
You know what computers should be doing,
guys.
Guys buy my idea about computers in
Russian. And they were like, dude weaver,
we have told you a million times.
You need to stop bothering us and just
write the stupid Russian thing down.
He sat down and he wrote the very first
memo on computer translation and it
really got the ball rolling.
First Ucla in Georgetown got on board
and then MIT followed in 1951 by giving
you a whole shoe, a bar, Hillel,
the position of full time professional
machine translation, Matt,
the first and the business.
Then in 1954 IBM in Georgetown stage,
the first public demo
of machine translation,
49 whole Russian sentences.
The crowd went wild.
Empty was the next big thing.
So how did they do it?
Well,
they started with the Russian sentence
and they broke it into its dictionary
chunks, you know, word and word
pieces like suffixes and roots.
Then they applied one of just six
rules to the chunks. For example,
here's the first rule. No,
no wait, we are programmers.
We count from zero.
So this is the zero with rule oh word
was associated with the code one 10 and
that code told the machine to go back and
look at the last full word and when it
found that last word,
it had a check that word for another
code 21 and if that word came up,
20 ones, the machine placed
it after the first word.
Now I know that sounds like
a whole bunch of steps,
but the result was pretty simple.
You take two words and you switch them
with only a fist full of rules like this.
The machine translated amazing sentences,
like magnitude of angle is determined by
the relation of length of arc to radius
and the price of potatoes
is termed by the demand.
Potatoes really machine,
culturally sensitive,
much in spite of that, the journalists
were impressed and the public,
they were stunned in a world that had
never seen computer smarts like this.
This was magic. But, uh,
if you peek behind that
curtain a little bit,
things start to feel a
tiny bit less magical.
The sentences had all
been carefully selected.
Everything was transliterated from
cyrillic into the Latin alphabet and
grammatically sentences included only
third person verbs and avoided any
negations are questions,
sometimes things that we would think of
as grammar or syntax restored as part of
the dictionary entries. And that
last one is actually pretty cheap.
Think about it.
This machine associates each Russian
word with up to two dictionary entries.
So there's a word that
translates to relation,
but if you look at the second
English choice, it's the relation.
Instead of figuring out a way to train
the computer to understand English
articles, they just shoved the word the
end as part of another dictionary choice.
So yeah,
they were doing a little bit of cheating,
but a only cheated a little bit,
but it did not matter to the public.
People were really excited and if you
weren't translating machine the times
we're good for now because when
we returned to wrap up this story,
things start to get ugly.
The nerds are going to be fighting over
how computers should be translating,
and the Public Starts Making a mockery
of grammar and the very existence of
machine translation will
hang in the balance. Chai.